it's up to us if we want to reunify and
I think that it happens on an individual
level when one person says they want to
connect with everything else they have
that opportunity
this episode is proudly sponsored by CM
Bois many of you watching have heard of
Tristan Harris in the Center for Humane
technology we've done many episodes on
the perverse incentives around screen
time and critically thinking about what
balance truly maximizes our potential
Sampo built a new smartphone interface
and browser extensions as the new home
screen for humanity they're at a
crossroads looking for a new CEO to come
in or to partner with a larger
organization that has the resources to
bring this incredible technology to the
world they've built a high integrity
foundation and are teed up for something
wonderful if interested message the
founder Andrew done at Andrew at cm poco
more infos in the bio thanks everyone
and enjoy that episode what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Don sock in we're on-site at the
transformative technology conference for
our second annual partnership with them
we are now gonna be talking with Brandon
Howard what's up Brandon not much doing
good how are you thanks for coming on
the program thanks for having me so
pumped for this me too I'm excited I
know yeah we're gonna be talking about
euphoria I'm excited about that
Before we jump into that we got to ask
you some of our questions that we ask
all of our guests are we really all one
well I definitely believe that that
answer is up to everyone I personally
feel connected to everyone
I'm almost driven by a sense of
responsibility for my contribution to
everyone and that level or that you know
path of thinking helps it helps me it's
helped me understand the past it helps
me experience the present and not worry
about the future I could go on for hours
so I you know whether it's science
whether it's
chu allottee whether it's you know
everybody's definition a common sense
people feel connections and you have to
go with your feelings
I think ignoring your feelings is like
cutting off you know some of your best
resources for for living and thriving
absolutely I love how you gave these two
sides of the same coin the science and
the spirituality marrying those two
seems like the most important one of the
most paramount things that we can
possibly do to ensure abundant and
prosperous world and future I want to
ask you next about your feelings of
interconnectedness has this been like a
feelings of of the drop rejoining the
ocean unconditional love deep present
moment has this been around egodeath you
know all these different take us through
some of your well that's that's a long
story but it started when I broke my
back or I had I was on the treadmill I
was running I was getting in shape for a
half marathon and I experienced a period
of pain that I didn't have a lot of
resources to combat with I wasn't gonna
be I was denied surgery and pain meds
were making me feel things I didn't
enjoy feeling it was actually like
almost enraging me and I noticed it
because my wife was responding to it and
so that's what sort of got me on this
journey and it it's required a lot of
self-reflection about essentially my
behavior and then I had to dig into like
why I was behaving certain ways like
what triggered that and that helped me
understand sort of how our subconscious
makes 95% of our decisions and that's
driven by how we were raised and all the
experiences we've had so I've had to
look back at each thing that sets me off
and figure out what's the best way to
combat that and as I'm learning and
understanding myself and understand what
other people have been through and
understanding you know the connections
between science and our bodies
it took me all the way back in history
to the point where science didn't exist
and everything was spiritual and that's
kind of where I saw how science took one
route and spirituality took another and
going back to your topic of oneness what
we're at now is completely like this is
called specialized
and there's so many schools of thought
that all come back to one if we decide
that we want to take it all the way back
there so if we've brought all these
schools and a few of the speaker's are
mentioning it that more the scientific
disciplines need to communicate and I
think that once they start unifying and
whoever starts to unify and Transtech is
already doing it but you start unifying
that science and that spirituality we're
getting back to the way it was
originally yeah but you have to commit
to one thing but that you can understand
the whole thing and then how about do
you think that our most
upstream issue for the reason why we
have so many of the issues in our world
is the illusion of separation that we
lack that interconnectedness yeah I
think I mean we can get into mythology
if you want to yeah it'd take us um but
there's this sort of there's stories out
there humanity has always been driven by
stories and stories are what help us
connect to the world around us and to
each other and the stories that resonate
the most with me are the ones that talk
about how we were all one like these
ancient stories like you know Atlantis
is like this myth that didn't exist like
I grew up in South Carolina it wasn't
talked about at all and then you start
hearing these little stories here and
there like it starts to add this
curiosity but you know if you dig deep
enough like the information is out there
and it'll it will explain how there was
this period where we were all one and we
knew that we were all one and then
regardless of what religion you look
into there was this separation and that
separation
is what's driven us to the direction
that were or the place that we're in now
and it's up to us if we want to reunify
and I think that it happens on an
individual level when one person says
they want to connect with everything
else they have that opportunity so it's
the priority of the drop rejoining the
ocean that makes it so that the
interconnectedness is able to thrive at
the grand scale the drop has to
consciously go into the process of
rejoining the ocean yeah yeah the yeah I
guess we're all we're all raindrops
we're all individual drops and you know
if you want to stay in the clouds and be
separate from the ocean that's up to you
but you know the journey is the fall
from the cloud and the ocean is that
soft landing that says like you're now
where you were always supposed to be yes
I like that letter for ya we've we've
even went and talked about how the
process of birth is when you start
dropping as the rain drop in that when
the entire you're the one that's when
you join the ocean but along the way you
have the ability to kind of add into the
water cycle along the way if you can
feel into it if you choose those who
feel it know it that style of of process
I have um I have so many other thoughts
around this I wanna but I do want to get
into euphoria I want to ask you about
what you're working on now how can we
and this actually kind of takes us into
this process of trying to help people
achieve the states of interconnectedness
sure our approach my approach was sort
of what spawned euphoria it was
understanding that this is an emotional
thing like I was raised to not express
too many emotions and I had a lot to
express you can ask my friends that I
grew up with I was an emotional kid and
that forced me to figure out how to
balance it all but dealing with all
these injuries made me realize that I
was suppressing it all and if you don't
mind reiterating your question because I
was on a path and I don't want to get
off of it yeah yeah about how
specifically euphoria does the helps
with interconnectedness sure so I wanted
to understanding that what I was going
through
was individual you know as I'm
understanding these things I came home
and I was giving my wife lectures on out
like everybody was supposed to be and it
was almost through those conversations
that I realized that what I'm
experiencing isn't what everybody else
is experiencing and so when I was using
euphoria in its early stages I realized
that I had the flexibility to not only
customize this experience for myself but
to let other people customize it for
themselves everybody's had different
experiences everybody has different
needs and you know the one
one-size-fits-all scenario doesn't work
it might work for a majority
I might work for a minority but I wanted
to create something that was completely
flexible and I'm also understanding that
not everybody's ready for infinite
options infinite opportunities you might
need to give them options to choose from
so the stage that we're at with euphoria
is it's out there it's available and
people can use it as they want to what
we want to do is help more people have
access to it and when it comes to like
you know new forms of technology they
might not gravitate to something that
says oh I can heal my emotions would
sound like don't even need to worry
about my emotions like is that really a
thing but I am seeing correlations
between you know emotions and behavior
and then the health impacts of those
choices that people make so we want to
you for you to give lots of people ways
to to find their own solutions and then
how do you figure out what is my
appropriate personalized by knurl
meditation solution mindful solution
well I could ask you like what's
bothering you what's your emotional
state or so like you prompt me to answer
questions
the service about what's bothering me or
what's my state sure so when you open
the app it'll ask you how do you want to
feel and so if you can answer that
question then there's a whole host of
emotions that you can choose bliss is
the most popular one and then as soon
yeah and then the next phase is what
personal attribute do you want to boost
your yourself your ability to express
yourself boost your focus boost your
your consciousness boost your your vigor
your vitality these are all parts of
yourselves that if you don't know how to
get into them
euphoria can help you connect with it
and then the more you do this the more
you realize is how in control you are
the less you'll actually need euphoria
so I wanted it to be you know a rainbow
bridge of sorts and then so then walk us
through like if I do select bliss like
what am i prompted to do so bliss the
way we see it is more of like a
consciousness experience and so you know
there's lots of feelings that you get
when you feel bliss and my version of
lism might be different than your
version of bliss and of the you know
twenty nine thousand people who have
downloaded you for you so far bliss is
the most popular but I think that
everybody would have their own
explanation of like how it feels but
it's always positive and we designed you
for you to only really include positive
experiences so that way people will
recognize do they feel good if you feel
good then it's working if something else
makes you feel good that's also working
but I wanted to make sure there were a
lot less side effects and what sound you
know we're surrounded by sound and we're
not even surrounded by healthy sound so
I really feel positive that this is
healthier than a lot of things that are
out there and then walk us through what
you do when I do select bliss or want
any of the users that you're talking
about do select bliss like what do I
experience three for you what does it
take me into so I want to use he's my
mom as an example so you know I watched
my mom raised me and I watched her going
to companies where she has had to carry
the weight of other people's
responsibilities and so I've seen like
her deal with stress and for her it's it
might be more challenging to find
happiness in different situations but
when I created euphoria and gave it and
gave it to her she she chose bliss and
she mixes it with her sleep and so some
people might want bliss in the office
some people might bliss want bliss while
they're relaxing she wants bliss while
she sleeps and when she wakes up
she actually feels like she just had a
great day she feels like she had a great
sleep and she starts her day with this
optimistic feeling that everything is
fine and you know these illusions of why
she's not happy she's recognizing them
now as illusions that she just needs to
change her perspective on and so you
give me a binaural experience that then
catalyze the states of bliss right right
so the frequencies that we use they're
based on the Solfeggio scale and what's
the skill called self a Gia
so I pronounced it I'm pretty sure it's
Italian so it that scale was developed
and again these Gregorian monks were
singing these tones to reach these sort
of emotional states that they preferred
and that particular frequency does
trigger those types of emotions and the
binaural the binaural part is more about
shifting into sleep mode or relaxation
mode or meditation mode like that sort
of physically gets you in your mind in
the direction you want to go the self
ezio tones are what trigger the
different emotions so just hearing a
particular note in a song like if you
hear that high note that might be the
reason you love that song when your
favorite musician just hits it hard and
you're like yes and you feel the
connection between them between you like
it's the right frequencies that's seeing
it's the right frequencies that our
bodies respond to and you know that
bliss frequency is it's you know it's
it's you know it feels like magic but
now that we're understanding the science
behind it and how it's triggering like
parts of your brain and body and
releasing hormones and you know we can
understand how we're responding to these
sense I like that example of you know
why we even put on a jam in the first
place is that we get to that moment
where it's just triggering some sort of
emotion or feeling for us that is
profound and so important
and so we have different music for
different ways we want to feel and so I
like then that you're able to identify
what you know what is for me a blissful
song maybe like a self NGO scale might
be similar for a majority of people it
might be somewhat different for
different people maybe some people don't
necessarily resonate with this super
blissful way what you may think is maybe
maybe they want something that's super
blissful that is only birds chirping and
water absolutely yeah absolutely
because if you look at there was a study
done where they compared the music that
we was to do traditionally and how music
is tuned and the story behind that but
you know it's probably a good place to
talk about it it was established in
Germany like in the I think the 20s or
30s 1930s and that you can fact check
that by the way but we decided to tune
music to the scale of a equals 440 now
that was tested against the self ojio
scale where they chose a popular
frequency of 528 Hertz and you could see
that the esophageal tone had a greater
impact on our emotions according to the
tests that they ran with the people in
the trial and so nature has a more
positive impact than the music we create
because we're tuning to the wrong notes
and so if we change the notes that we
tend to we don't need to stop listening
to birds but we're getting what the
birds are offering we're getting what
nature is offering because you know
their notes do resonate with us
on a deeper level and I think that's
sort of like the cloud of sound that we
live in whether it's traffic or
construction or you know poorly tuned
music like all this stuff has a
psychological impact on us whether we
realize it is not absolutely yeah we
were just talking about that a couple of
days ago around this conversation about
what aspects of a well being today are
actually lower than they were in the
past and this is very contrary in to
what so many people have been saying
today is the best time to be alive it's
like this drum that people are beating
overall a positive yet like you just
described I we all know that our input
stream that we constantly taken on a
moment-to-moment basis being overly
saturated with traffic construction all
these things when you walk down in a
metropolis makes us feel completely
different it makes me feel like I'm
inside of the matrix and then when I'm
in nature and I'm deeply immersed in
bird sounds waterfalls the leaves
blowing in the wind I mean it's just
game over I feel like I'm in
interconnected beyond yea the matrix
basically creates an environment of
disconnection and so I do think that
that may be an aspect of our well-being
that has actually decreased when we find
ourselves in the matrix metropolis is
versus when we find we used to find
ourselves more immersed deeply in nature
yeah I agree
and it's even the structure of buildings
um there was a TED talk on how sound can
be used or how you can construct things
to promote better use of sound and
straight walls are not it sound just
bounces awkwardly off of it and so in
nature that doesn't happen probably
because of its fractal nature and so
what we need to consider is how we
construct our buildings our rooms our
cities the the machines that we use I
mean there's all these studies about the
the animal mints that construction
workers have because of the vibrations
that they're surrounded by and I don't
know if that means changing what hammers
are made out of or how gears grind or if
we can augment the sound and vibration
that these machines are giving off so
that it that is at least healthier and
how they're doing their constructions
and beyond that if we're creating places
that are healthier for us to be in I
think that we're going to feel a lot
better yeah yeah this is paramount it's
that are built environments that we've
chose to design
are not conducive towards spiritual
wholeness and well-being they're more
oriented towards something that is
unnatural Lee has a proclivity towards
unnatural Ness rather than something
that's way more like even just take it
take into account the the like basically
every single building that were in just
that there's the idea of natural light
is not even the first priority the idea
of having a plants and water and animals
inside is not even first priority it's
it's about like square footage and about
productivity and about you know any
actually if you were to try and build
things around productivity you have
natural light animals plants and all
those things that's actually first
because you would have a more productive
if you could basically walk into a
building and have that building be
basically like an office in the middle
of the woods yeah that was the exact
idea popping into my head as you were
like discussing all of that it's just
like you like just you just drive down
this long drive light into the woods and
like the offices are under canopies and
trees and animals are walking right
through like yeah like I would love to
work in that office like let's build
that office yeah wow that's such a
game-changer yeah I love that and it's
it's you're absolutely right you're
right on your right you're spot-on in my
opinion like we're definitely on the
same wavelength when it comes to the
potential is out there and maybe that's
why it's the best time to be alive right
now because we have the resources to
bring our ideas into fruition it's just
you know the past several thousand years
of us you know thinking that one way is
best and maybe that was the way we
needed to get to this point like there's
a lot of infrastructure built and but
it's like hard for us to fix it because
it's it wasn't the best infrastructure
so how do we augment that current
infrastructure we have because it's
probably way too expensive to like knock
everything down and rebuild it and
that's why cities seem to bounce from
place to place like that city worked for
a while and now we need to build new
cities and new places and new ways and
see if they can last even longer yeah
yeah I love it and we're literally
talking about you know cities inside of
the Redwood cities alongside the
coastlines and not cities the way that
we currently see beach towns and stuff
like that but in the sense of like very
very the what would it look like if you
were to try and jump into like mixing
together what like immediate return
hunter-gathering is with the
computational modernity of today like
that would be what I would love to see
some mix between those two things like
me being able to live in a in a you know
in in a like in a very like primordial
environment but that is still heavily
has the ability to get interconnected
into the internet grid as I as I please
and like being able to add between those
is just like you you literally like
garden during the day between your
shifts on the internet and then you at
night you have a fire and look up at the
cosmos without light pollution I mean
it's like that though these are
game-changing yeah ways to build the
future yeah you're speaking my
shangri-la but I it's all it's all
possible and I think that you know
giving the systems that we have right
now I think that you could have a
hackathon and talk about you know what's
a new way to build an office like in a
remote place and I know my my idea would
be almost like a log cabin type open
office space where it is that throwback
cabin in the woods so you feel like it's
rustic Oh
I really don't want to cut down too many
trees if we can avoid that but so
there's new materials out there but it
can look like whatever we want because
now we know how to like do that and we
can find ways to do it safely and
organically and again like you know if
it's hard for each individual to be one
with each other I think that individuals
are finding that it's a lot easier to be
one with nature and so if we put
ourselves in nature and then say how can
we make nature how we optimize this
environment for us without doing harm
then you know we just got a look at
what's worked in the past I mean there's
all these questions about 5g and like
how safe is that yeah meanwhile Tesla's
putting electricity through the ground
and I think that we should explore like
is that safe for the environment like
our plants thriving from this or or what
but we need to take a smart approach to
it but you can I mean an on/off switch
for the internet like in a remote place
in the woods because you're passing
electricity through the ground like yeah
to me that's just why not try it yeah
yeah I want to know on the binaural beat
side especially for those that aren't
familiar walk us through what exactly
that feels like what is that how do you
end up creating something that can
auditorally stimulate states of
consciousness do you mean what does it
feel like for me creating that or what
does it feel like for the person listen
a person was tuning um I guess I've got
to think about what is it like for me
and I listen so and what is like the
science itself behind like a binaural
sure so when it comes to binaural beats
your brain your your brain vibrates
essentially and it measurably it
vibrates at different you know bands of
frequency and when you're asleep you're
considered during Delta stage when
you're you know the next stop for a
relaxation of meditation that's like the
theta range and so it goes up to alpha
and gamma essentially the binaural beat
part when that comes in is creating a
vibration that your brain is going to
sing
up with so sympathetic vibration is what
your brain does and the binaural beats
create that energetic environment for
your brain to figure out okay how do you
want me to vibrate and so it just puts
you there it puts your brain where your
brain is used to being and so whether
you're dealing with anxiety like you
know yesterday I was all worried about
the pitch that I had to give I've been
thinking about it for weeks and I was
trying to get into that mental place of
knowing that everything's gonna be fine
and so I adjusted my binaural beats to
be in relaxed mode and that relaxed mode
that theta mode has so many benefits you
learn better when you're relaxed bless
you thank you um you learn better your
blood pressure drops your heart rate
like slows and then like all these
things that are your body naturally does
it's hard for you to force your brain to
get you in that state unless you have
some other tool to get you there now
there's other tools out there I mean you
could breathe you can meditate you could
just if you do yoga or maybe for other
people it's running or exercise so
there's this whole spectrum that gets
you in that right state of mind
but binaural beats allow you to just put
on headphones and listen for 10 minutes
and then it gets all those processes
moving in that direction so it kind of
catalyzes from the auditory centers of
our nervous system these feelings of
calmness interconnectedness the
decreases in blood pressure heart rate
sure it's essentially you're triggering
your endocrine system the endocrine
system right so when when you're faced
with something that stresses you out
your natural response is going to be for
your subconscious to use all your past
experiences and decide what's the best
approach for you so if you're allowing
yourself conscious to decide how you
want to handle a situation how you want
to handle a stress it might
automatically just say like alright I'm
scared of that let's release hormones
that are designed to help us run from
our problems and if those problems are
always just chasing you you never get
rid of that cycle of releasing negative
stress-related hormones from your
sympathetic nervous system now you have
a moment and that's sort of where I
think that this
zero point kind of is where you get to
choose fight versus flight like I
normally hear people say that it's fight
or flight and that's just like one thing
that you do like when you're scared but
for me it's you know you can choose to
run or you can choose to face it head-on
and when you choose to face something
you start to activate your
parasympathetic nervous system and that
helps you calm down and helps you know
be in the moment to figure out what do
you need to do to deal with this
situation and I played basketball and so
for me I correlate that to the zone and
when you're in the zone you see
everything you feel everything
everything feels natural everything
feels easy and there's just no stress
now I played under a lot of stress so I
didn't experience the zone very much but
when you look at superstars they stay in
the zone whether it comes naturally or
they just know how to get there and so I
see tech that triggers you into the zone
yeah that was my that was that was sort
of a result of everything that I was
doing I initially came to binaural beats
because I was experiencing pain and
didn't know how to deal with it and out
of all those suggestions like more sleep
more relaxation and meditation I needed
help with meditation so I used binaural
beats to get me into that meditative
state of mind so I could experience the
benefits and the hormones that get
released and all the healing that
happens but I was surprised when I found
out that the healing was actually
breaking down all these subconscious
behaviors that were leading me into
unhealthy decisions yeah yeah yeah so
it's so it's as though once you do the
tech that triggers us into these deeper
interconnected states that this this
this if this effect also happens where
we heal some of the most deepest parts
of our psyche through that and you just
it ends up just butterfly effecting into
the rest of our lives right don't get
triggered as easily we are able to more
quickly reach interconnected states on
our own away from the tech as well it's
just it's
profoundly a butterfly effect
yeah and said I love I love how you how
you put that out I love that yeah yeah
yeah this is good this is some euphoria
app calm yep you4ii
a da app calm one more to you for ei
app.com a PP calm yeah okay we're there
buta for EA app calm everyone yeah check
that out for sure and that's on both of
the major platforms it's only on iOS
only on iOS yeah I have navigated the
world of entrepreneurship and
fundraising and dealing with existing
industries and processes to go from my
friends and family that understand and
support and I've been there for me and I
wouldn't be here without them and
they've allowed me to try to get the
investment just to get it on Android and
the other platforms and so we've
actually had to take more of a business
approach to figure out how to introduce
this to more people and so we're trying
to help corporations because of their
motivations to know reduce the stress
and anxiety of their employees so they
perform better yeah and so if we can get
corporations to create customized
versions of euphoria then that'll allow
us to you know generate the revenue to
build out the app so it's available for
everybody on other platforms yeah yeah
that's another good one I mean we were
just talking to George from my field and
he's doing the process of working with
the with insurance and medical and just
diving right into 10,000 person
companies and bringing the tech to them
and I think that's a very interesting
way to try and get transformative
technologies into the world is through
the pitch to corporations on
productivity but just in general that at
the same time while I'm saying that I'm
going like no Alan
I know what like like like don't get
your app into your transformer
technology app I mean it's okay but like
it's just like I also just like you know
just say what's on your mind if it gets
trapped in there you got warm problems
more more like it's more like taking
this to companies that are already doing
destructive things just get the people
that are there to become more productive
versus trying to just get those old
archaic companies to die so we can build
a new world but maybe bringing
transformative technology and does
awaken people more and then they decide
that what they're doing is [ __ ] anyway
so yeah thank you it's funny that
corporations typically have this like
freedom to do things without worrying
about consequences just from like a
legal standpoint and so it's almost as
if like you've got you know whether it's
a toddler a baby a giant or whatever
like that size corporation has never had
to self-reflect and it's not going to
until the people inside self-reflect and
I think that you know any businesses
tries to do any business that's doing
harm is setting itself up to sort of
experience that corporate Karma
and so I think that by I think naturally
as the people inside the companies start
to change then the companies will start
to change their motivations and they
have so many resources to get things
done that I think it's better for them
to make those adjustments and provide
for a better future or you know other
companies are going to thrive and
eventually replace because they're doing
new things and new ways that are
resonating with with the general
population this phrase corporate Karma
yeah I don't know if somebody else has
said that to you I don't think I've
heard corporate Karma yet I like that I
just yeah and the corporate Karma is
hopefully what gets us to awaken more
I see I see that as well I like that
just couple quick questions on the way
out do you think that humanity is a
biological bootloader for digital super
intelligence biological boots like neo
like is humanity's purpose to build
digital super intelligence like
artificial general intelligence purpose
is experience we can get back into you
know the theory of one or feeling that
oneness and sort of the whole point of
creation the whole point of creation and
that's just it the point is creation and
I think that you know if you look at
spirituality on a dimensional level you
know there are higher dimensions and
we're on level three and we seem to have
created level two with digital and
virtual reality like sure these are like
40 experiences but we're experiencing
through a 3d like body and so yeah I
think that it's about creation but it
needs to be creation with positive
intent so yeah our bodies essentially
designed to carry like spiritual energy
like I completely believe that and I
think that that spiritual energy is what
drives us to continue to want to create
there are the purpose of creation being
creation yeah the becoming miss that
becoming more alive yeah expressing
itself uniquely yeah because I have been
expressing myself commonly like trying
to like fit in be normal and I didn't
have that insight to be original until
you finally realized that not being
original it's harmful for you so
everybody has to give what they give
what they have and hopefully have a good
time doing it and so long as intent is
positive you know there's there
shouldn't be a limit to what we're
capable of yeah in what do you think's
the most beautiful thing in creation
well love is the easy answer I mean
anything that can pull you push you
drive you motivate you
and you know how it works is incredible
how it works is amazing how you feel you
feel so much more when love is the
awareness that you have or I could say
Xbox I love video games and I think that
you know they create an environment for
new experiences and it allows you for me
it allows my mind to you know create my
own was that movie um
Total Recall where you get to like just
go do something different for a little
while you can get away from doing the
same old same old
and the more experiences you can create
and that's what's great some of the real
life experiences are like too expensive
too far away like to meet people that
have never left their city or their
state like that's how I saw that there
was so much more to the world and that's
why I want to keep exploring it but you
know in the meantime you know I can have
like a little daily break yeah yeah yeah
love and Xbox yeah III vibe I vibe
though because this is made of atoms and
the world of bits is just we can be gods
in that world a little bit more we are
gods here too but it's just so cool to
design virtual worlds and immerse
ourselves in them and that kind of
process I'm a huge huge fan of but it
can also be hard because then how much
have you mastered the world of atoms
prior to entering just the world of bits
and then oh yeah we
there's just way more for us to know and
to explore and experiment on it's just
it's just a matter of resources and I
think that you know the transformative
technology community completely gets
that and we come together and we provide
our individual contributions and that
grows into deeper understandings for how
atoms work and and what we can do with
them and I think that's going to
transform how we live and it's gonna
clearly transform everything we create
yeah
yeah um thank you so much for coming on
the show Brannon this has been a blast I
really appreciate you I appreciate it
thank you for having me this has been
awesome and I can't wait to see more I
mean your conversations yeah thanks
brother I appreciate that
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it left to hear your thoughts
in the comments below on the episode let
us know should think and check out the
links in the bye blow to Brandon's work
okay let me see if I can get this you
for the number EA app a PP dot-com
perfect perfect boom there you go and
then you got that in the bio check that
out also check out the links to
transformative technology conference as
well check out those links in the bio
blow to the community also support the
artists the entrepreneurs the spiritual
leaders the organizations around the
world that you believe it in your
communities you can find all of our
links to simulation and are in the bio
below PayPal patreon cryptocurrency get
Zog design cool merchants get paid all
those links are below and go and build
the future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world we live very much thank
you for tuning in and we will see you
soon
namaste namaste
[Music]